en algorithmique et en intelligence
artificielle rien que ça eh bien vous
demande d'applaudir alexandre morel il y
à très très longtemps
un homme des cavernes a ramassé un bâton
qui traînait par terre avec ce bâton il
pouvait frapper plus fort et plus loin
il venait ainsi sans le savoir de
devenir le premier humain augmenté de
l'histoire et depuis ce jour nous
n'avons cessé d'inventer de nouvelles
prothèses des prothèses de jambes pour
nous déplacer beaucoup plus vite des
prothèses de mémoire pour stocker une
quantité d'informations quasi illimitée
des prothèses dieu pour permettre aux
gens comme moi de voir beaucoup moins
floue et comme vous pouvez le voir j'ai
également une prothèse de voix afin que
les gens au fond de la salle puisse
m'entendre
mais attendez j'en ai une meilleure avec
cette prothèse là ma voix porte
tellement loin qu'on peut entendre
jusqu'à l'autre bout du monde
incroyable bon là je vous ai parlé du
passé à présent
parlons de l'avenir si nous continuons à
nous augmenté ou est ce que cela nous
amène et bien cela pourrait nous amener
à ce que certains appellent le
transhumanisme le transhumanisme c'est
l'idée que nous pouvons dépasser nos
limitations biologique avec la
technologie
je vais vous donner quelques exemples
bon tout d'abord commençons avec un truc
simple le contrôler par la pensée
dans cette expérience de l'université de
standford on voit une personne
entièrement paralysé mais grâce à un
dispositif
elle parvient à contrôler un curseur de
souris sur un ordinateur par la seule
force de sa pensée
elle peut ainsi taper du texte et donc
communiqué alors bien sûr c'est encore
un stade un petit peu rudimentaire mais
si cette technologie progresse on peut
imaginer un nombre incroyable
d'application par exemple je fais le
pari que les jeux vidéo du futur se
joueront entièrement par la pensée on
pourra peut-être même taper du texte
directement par la pensée simplement en
pensant à une phrase
voire même pourquoi pas communiquer
directement par la pensée et là encore
des chercheurs ont déjà réussi à le
faire de façon rudimentaire alors un des
principaux aspects du transhumanisme
c'est bien sûr l'idée de vivre beaucoup
plus longtemps pas d'être vieux plus
longtemps bien sûr l'idée c'est de
ralentir le vieillissement de le stopper
voire même pourquoi pas de l'inverser
afin de rester le plus longtemps
possible en pleine forme et en pleine
possession de nos moyens
alors ça peut vous sembler complètement
fou mais le vieillissement n'est pas une
fatalité biologique
il existe des organismes comme par
exemple cette méduse qui sont
biologiquement et mortelle ces cellules
peuvent se renouveler indéfiniment et on
a déjà réussi à prolonger de façon très
importante la durée de vie de verre et
de mouches et en 2018 on a même réussi à
inverser le vieillissement de cellules
humaines
alors bien sûr rester jeunes pendant des
siècles ce sera un objectif extrêmement
ambitieux mais si on y met les moyens
il est probable que l'on fasse des
progrès très important dans cette
direction
et enfin il y à tout ce qui touche à
l'augmentation de nos capacités
cognitives
nous sommes des primates qui par un
hasard de l'évolution avons développé un
cerveau très complexe mais on pourrait
imaginer avoir un cerveau encore plus
complexe dépenser encore plus
sophistiqué des émotions encore plus
intense bref tout cela nous emmène loin
et certains disent que le transhumanisme
c'est la quête de l'homme parfait et en
général quand on dit ça ben ça fait un
froid parce que à quoi est ce qu'on
pense quand on entend un homme parfait à
une armée de clones blond aux yeux bleus
avec un code barre sur le front qui
mènent tous une existence parfaite et
parfaitement fientes
c'est pas très réjouissant comme tableau
mais je ne pense pas que le
transhumanisme ce soit la quête de
l'homme parfait parce que si l'avenir de
l'humanité
c'était de tous devenir des humains
parfait et bien le futur ça
ressemblerait à quelque chose comme ça
et moi le futur ben je le vois plus tôt
comme ça un truc qui fait peur aux gens
par exemple c'est l'idée que si nous
sommes totalement libre de choisir nos
caractéristiques biologiques
nous allons tous convergé vers des
standards de beauté parfait et au final
tout le monde se rassemblera et on aura
perdu en diversité mais c'est pas
vraiment comme ça qu'on fonctionne
imaginez qu'à une époque donnée il ya un
acteur extrêmement populaire qui
s'appelle steve beaucoup de parents vont
donc suivre la mode et appuyer leurs
enfants steve mais au bout d'un moment
si beaucoup de gens s'appelle steve ça
va devenir un petit peu banal voire
ringard désolé c'est des gens qui
s'appelait ce type dans la salle c'est
juste un exemple
et au final aujourd'hui les prénoms sont
tout aussi diversifiée qui lie à 50 ans
parce que nous avons tous un besoin
important celui de nous singulariser
dans certains jeux vidéo on peut créer
son personnage comme on le souhaite et
si tous les joueurs chercher à se
conformer aux standards de beauté
tous les personnages se ressembleraient
or beaucoup de joueurs choisissent
d'incarner des personnages comme ceci
donc si nous nous sommes davantage libre
de choisir nos caractéristiques
biologiques
je ne pense pas que cela va mener à
l'uniformisation
je pense aux comptes a que cela va mener
à une explosion de diversité une autre
idée que j'entends souvent c'est si nous
vivons pendant des siècles
au bout d'un moment on aura tout vu tout
fait tout essayé je connais des gens qui
me disent si on vit pendant 500 ans
qu'est-ce qu'on va s'ennuyer alors je ne
suis pas d'accord avec ce point de vue
mais un point vous n'imaginez pas prenez
un instant pour réfléchir au nombre de
livres que vous pourriez lire au nombre
d'oeuvres que vous pourriez créer au
nombre de choses que vous pourriez
comprendre ou expérimentés au nombre de
personnes que vous pourriez rencontrer
au nombre d'expériences que vous
pourriez faire même si vous viviez à 200
à l'heure
ce que je ne vous conseille pas rester
zen vous n'arriveriez pas à faire un
milliardième de ce que l'on pourrait
faire en l'espace d'une vie et là je ne
parle que des choses que nous
vont faire aujourd'hui mais comme le
monde continue d'évoluer
la quantité de choses à faire augmente
tellement vite que nous ne pourrons
jamais tout faire imaginez par exemple
les possibilités qui s'ouvrira à nous si
on finissait par développer des univers
virtuels plus vrai que nature donc plus
nous avançons dans le temps et plus le
pourcentage de choses que nous aurons
fait deviendra infime
le peintre salvador dali disait n'ayez
pas peur d'atteindre la perfection vous
n'y arriverez jamais et ben moi
j'ajouterais n'ayez pas peur d'avoir
tout fait dans la vie vous n'y arriverez
jamais même si vous vivez très très
longtemps
alors est ce que je suis en train de
dire que tout est rose que tout est
merveilleux
non bien sûr depuis l'invention du feu
toute technologie à ses bénéfices et ses
risques mais si la technologie était un
fleuve
il serait très difficile de l'arrêter
nous pourrions construire des barrages
mais l'eau finit par s'accumuler par
s'infiltrer et par trouver son chemin et
pas toujours celui qu'on souhaite ce
qu'on peut faire en revanche c'est dévié
le fleuve du progrès technologique dans
des directions qui nous semblent
davantage favorable on pourrait par
exemple se demandait comment minimiser
les risques des futures technologies ou
comment faire en sorte que tout le monde
y ait accès de façon davantage
égalitaire afin de ne pas créer une
société dystopique à deux vitesses mais
imaginons que l'on puisse tout arrêté
d'un coup faudrait-il de faire
faudrait-il à partir de demain matin
perpétuer le même mode de vie pour les
siècles des siècles je trouverais ça un
petit peu dommage parce que ça voudrait
dire au fond que l'humain tel qu'il est
actuellement est tellement parfait qui
ne seraient souffrir d'aucune évolution
alors on peut voir les choses comme ça
mais on peut aussi considérer que
l'humain est un être en perpétuel
devenir alors est-ce que le
transhumanisme nous emmène vers l'homme
parfait vers une perfection statique et
figé je ne pense pas je pense au
contraire que le monde va devenir de
plus en plus complexes
et vertigineux mais cela dépend
également de nous et des choix que nous
faisons au quotidien parce que cette
idée d'une perfection glaçante qui nous
fait peur d'une certaine manière c'est
nous qui la crée on d'un côté elle nous
effraie mais en même temps une partie
d'une partie de nous l'idéalisme et les
futures évolutions technologiques seront
à l'image de ce que nous désirons
aujourd'hui on pourrait par exemple
désirez avoir une montre de luxe d'une
certaine marque afin de réussir sa vie
avant 50 ans mais nous pouvons aussi
vouloir d'autres choses plus original
plus intéressante plus diversifiée d'une
certaine manière nous aurons l'huma
augmente et que nous méritons
alors réfléchissons bien à ce que nous
idéalise on a ce que nous désirons à ce
que nous valorisons socialement parce
que c'est cela qui dès aujourd'hui
détermine le monde de demain
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]